[Applause]
John that was the nerdfighter gathering
that you missed because of your stupid
gallbladder everyone who's there I think
can attest that it was fun without you
none the last evanna lynch both looks
and sounds like wooden love good weird
digging of meeting famous people VidCon
is like eight days away
I would be crazier but I hurt my neck at
LeakyCon oh hey check it out I'm wearing
Milan Hardcastle cherylin Hardcastle
shirt pretty freaking sweet I look hot
in it check out my pecs yeah PAC so yes
if you want your pecs to look good this
is the shirt for you I'm not wearing the
ladies one so I don't know I'm not gonna
talk about your pecs ladies somebody
gave me these at leakycon I'm putting
them on right now what are they yeah I'm
putting them up there love yeah yeah you
guys you go at it yeah oh that's hot
really it should be two dudes from what
we've learned about giraffe love oh my
god thank you today I have an idea let's
act out my entire album I just had this
idea with these giraffes okay go
this is not Harry Potter this is not
Harry Potter sick of the Shakers worry
of being the occasion with staffing
you heard about my thought
[Music]
paradox if they're like don't think of
McGowan see just keep them
there's a lot of ways to make a big
openings on cable news seem so freakin
dumb and weekend only on Channel Ed Lee
at an Earth Day birthday in 1989 and for
buffle minutes Purdue wasn't known each
other that cemento came along if bridges
started writing songs for a girl I
changed my mind the song Oh threesome
that was weird that was all 15 songs my
album in a minute in 20 seconds
these aren't lyrics the lyrics are
online these are actually the
descriptions of the song we did not
initially send out the email telling you
how to send me your 10 word scripts we
have now done that and if you bought
this CD at leakycon or are bound to buy
it at VidCon send your picture of
yourself with the CD so I know that you
have it and along with your script and I
will I will make your video we're also
because of the confusion extending the
time period I'm clearly not going to be
filming until after VidCon so let us
extend the offer if you buy in the next
14 days then I will take your 10 word
scripts I will make a video and I will
put it on my new Hardcastle videos
youtube channel which I will link to
below also if you have bought the
physical CD don't forget to listen to
the last track which is a secret track
and it has some instructions for you if
you would like to be in a music video
with me oh and I just got off the phone
with billboard billboard the people who
do music charts they called me and they
were like we just saw that this album is
charting and we're not sure what it is
and I was like yeah but that's my album
they wanted to know some information
about it so that they could put it in
the freaking charts in the charts people
you made me chart on Billboard that was
only a half pretend cry I'm a little bit
teary John I'll see you on Wednesday